hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again we
have some interesting news to talk about
today we have the state of balance a few
other bits like content of the week a
road map and I know you saw the title
I'm gonna explain that later in the
video just give me a bit to get through
all the majority of the information but
as always like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new and let's get
started with today's video first up is
the road map and you're gonna be seeing
a lot of similar things like the weekly
challenges in our cave quest but we're
gonna be getting some double loot on the
27th as well as content of the week
today which we'll get to a title update
coming the next few weeks and a new
event coming for December 19th which is
really interesting obviously we have no
idea what that's going to be but there's
probably going to be a dead stream
showing off all that stuff so as always
just keep out keep on the lookout for
those videos and when they come out I
can't wait to talk about the new event
I'm very excited to see if we're gonna
be getting for this stuff for the new
content of the week it's gonna be elite
outfits they're not too crazy but I
usually find that battle outfits and
elite outfits really come in clutch when
you're trying to find that perfect color
scheme for the character really not so
much the designs and stuff that comes
with it but most of the color scheme I
will be showing all four of them each
perfection I'm not even gonna bother
pronouncing half of these names because
I know I'm gonna get them wrong so we'll
just leave it at that next up is the new
state of balance and this is going to be
for season 11 so anything that has to do
with soon des or this season does not it
will not be included within this data so
just keep that in mind and there's going
to be a lot of different info being
shown so let me just simplify this real
quick basically this is gonna be the
main chart that we'll be talking about
in a second and on the very right side
of the screen is going to be your
overall rate for the character so kind
of like an average the middle numbers
are a percentage so at the top we have a
shoe go key at 45 meaning when shoe go
key
he has a 45 percent of a chance or win
rate against a heat so kiri heat so kiri
of course is going to have the exact
opposite which is 55 55 plus 45 is a
hundred so it evens out so if an
opponent or somebody has 30% then
against an opponent that means that that
opponent has a 70% chance of winning
against that specific hero which we'll
see towards the bottom as you can see
from shinobi
a picture we're not gonna be going over
it just yet I just want to go briefly
mention all the stuff and then we're
gonna go dive a little bit into the
grittier details in one second but we
also have pic rate and that's pretty
obvious that this is just between every
player which is the overall section and
then people that are Platinum Plus so
platinum diamond Grand Master players
you're above average experienced players
and ranked that's going to be this
percentage to kind of get a bit of
different data from each side that's a
pic rate is the next table is actually a
tier list made by the competitive
community and this image actually has a
lot more things going on than just this
picture so if you do want to see how
your main stacks up against all the
different game modes except - brief
sadly from the minds of a competitive
community click the link in the
description it'll take you to a
spreadsheet has a bunch of different
things explaining all the different
roles that they go into with the 4v4
game modes and then also how they stack
up against certain characters and then
the pros and cons and why they're being
put in certain sections as you're seeing
on screen I can't explain all of this
because there's a deck that's like an
entire video in itself for like 30
minutes long so just click the link in
the description if you're curious to see
what other people in the community think
but back to the images we're at the dual
tier list and this is the top 3 it
characters for the highest overall rate
is hito kiri shougo key and Raider with
the bottom of being Highlander PK and
shinobi according to the data from every
player in this instance some interesting
notes are that shinobi's numbers have a
lot of 20s and 30s meaning those
specific opponents have a lot of 60s and
70s against him meaning he's losing a
hell of a lot more matches than he's
winning
whereas hito carry is the complete
opposite having a lot of 60s and 70s
across the board - of you characters
meaning she's winning a lot more matches
than she's losing once again this is
based off every player meaning good and
bad players and this really is just
giving you really a rough idea of where
some of the characters are and you can
pause and check your mains numbers if
you want if you're just genuinely
curious next is the table next is the
same exact table but for diamond players
and roughly you're above average player
base so I couldn't get the best image
for this I do apologize but for the top
three we're gonna have Raider hito kiri
and law bringer with
bottom being centurion at glider and
shinobi Ritter hito kiri are clearly
staying on top and the you're gonna be
seeing them a lot up there as well and
shinobi is still on the bottom you're
also going to be seeing him down there
as well throughout the rest of this
video once again pause if you want to
check your main comparing some
above-average players but really nothing
Crazy's going on just a lot of you know
similarities here for the diamond
players compared to the overall
characters now we're gonna be talking
about Dominion and the Wulin are on the
bottom for the picks but JJ is almost on
top for the winds like anusha except not
as high on the list as well she's also
at the very bottom but her wins are
roughly towards the middle like I said
she has a point nine percent of the pick
right yet she has a 47% win rate which
is pretty solid
you know new shiz caltrops can be pretty
good in Dominion they're very effective
in breach but for Dominion they're okay
and honestly she's not too great but
she's also not as bad as everyone thinks
she is obviously judging by the win rate
Raider is obviously not leaving the top
three anytime soon and shinobi is not
getting out of the bottom three any time
soon maybe this will get the debb's to
maybe make the shinobi get a rework or
an overall for his whole kit and maybe
just not a few moves cuz I feel like
he's extremely lacking in this game and
I also hate half of his moveset just
because of the ranged attacks that he
has for a game that's supposed to be all
close quarters but I digress the last
one though is breach and this is also
very interesting how shinobi is still on
the bottom who would have thought that
but your man gundar's actually on the
top for the pick and they're also mid
for wins this could be a little bit
inflated seeing as your man Gunder was
the new character for that season so a
lot of people are going to be picking
him so that's automatically going to
boost the pick rate but he's pretty mild
for the wins and that's pretty
impressive I saw I think this might be a
little bit of an inflation I don't
really think many players were picking
urine because he was actually solid your
arm is a good character but nothing
crazy to be at the very top and taking
over characters like Raider and he's
okay in this instance and yeah that's
really it but I do want to bring up the
reasoning for the title I went out when
we were watching the dead stream and I
was watching it through the developers
were talking with the state of balance
and you know I'm just gonna roll the
clip
she was happy to be here we'll see you
guys next season for the Sunday night
results and now we're gonna throw it
back to Mike and Clarissa for info we'll
see you guys next season so yeah maybe
I'm reaching with this just a little bit
but we really haven't heard anything
about your for coming to the game and
seeing his run the last season of the
year I would like to get some new info
on what's happening for next year if
there is a next year I know they're
still they still have armor they're
still updating spectator mode and all
that glorious stuff so that's really
just kind of pushing the fact that we
have a fourth year of the game but it's
always nice to get a little confirmation
to ease our minds and I think this kinda
was it but I would still probably wait
for an official release of them kind of
talking about what their plans are for
next year as well yeah I like the V if
you do enjoy guys subscribe if you're
new I cover the informational side of
foreigner that being the balance changes
the here updates the patch notes the
leaks if you want to be kept up to date
with everything happening within the
world of foreigner and never miss out an
update definitely subscribe the channel
the guys take care have a great sterday
and peace out
you